The sports world is full of accomplished
competitors. In many cases, it's a family
affair. Two-time NBA MVP Steph Curry, and
reigning NFL MVP Patrick Mahomes, had
dads who played pro ball. The father of
iconic New England Patriots coach Bill
Belichick literally wrote the book on
coaching. Indeed, having a parent who was
a professional athlete turns out to be a
huge leg up when it comes to pursuing
this glamorous, lucrative line of work.
How should we feel about this? And how
should it inform our thoughts about
educational equity? On the one hand, it's
patently unfair. Some children get a huge
head start. On the other hand, parents
will inevitably share passions, knowledge,
and natural gifts with their children. In
fact, doing so is pretty much the
definition of good parenting. There are a
host of troubling ways in which
advantage is reproduced, but there are
also organic, socially beneficial ways in
which responsible parents may
incidentally advantage their children,
and well-meaning reformers committed to
educational equity need to respect that
complicated reality.
What lessons do you
think sports can teach about equity and
advantage? Let us know in the comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.